I assume since you're here,
uh,
that most of you know who I am,
but just for a little
bit of context setting,
I am going to talk a little bit about
the background of my company and why
that's relevant.
Because the book that I've written a is
a combination of a memoir about my time
in the technology industry,
a business book,
and an economic call to
action now on the economics.
How was my thesis advisor? Uh,
the book was, it was, it was, uh,
uh, really, uh, uh, uh,
I don't really know that much
about economics, although
a couple of people said,
well, but your instincts are good. Uh, but
how, uh, corrected my instincts in many,
many cases,
uh,
but any errors in the economics
portions are not house responsibility,
but he definitely would,
it would read a passage he read
multiple times and he would say, no,
you have to go read this paper. Oh,
you have to read, go read this paper.
It was a wonderful education and, uh,
I hope to continue it as I go
further down this path. Anyway,
so I'm the founder and CEO of
O'reilly media. Uh, you know,
most of you probably maybe
first, uh, new of us,
uh, as a publisher of the iconic
animal books. This book now,
I think it's still in its sixth edition,
VI and Van,
the first edition was in 1985 was one
of the first books I ever published. Uh,
I think it was in an
addition of 100 copies a,
it's gone on to sell probably a million
copies since then. It's still in print.
Uh, you know, however many years later,
32 years later. Uh, but you know,
we continue to be a publisher with this.
Here's a book that we did recently with
Google on site reliability engineering,
another book on,
on a hands on machine learning with
psychic learn and tensor flow. You know,
these are kind of the thing that a
lot of people in the computer industry
learned of us from. It's now only
about 20% of our business. Uh,
but the thing I'm kind of the proudest
of is the role that I've had in spreading
big ideas about where the industry
is going and what it ought to do.
Um, so very early in the nineties, uh,
my company created the
first commercial website,
the site called the global network
navigator was sort of before Yahoo.
It was the first web portal.
It was also the first, uh,
advertising supported
site on the worldwide web.
The Internet was still noncommercial
and did a lot of activism for, uh,
uh, the commercial internet and, uh,
also for the open commercial
internet in the very early days.
For those of you who weren't around then
the Internet was a research network.
And I still remember a conversation
I had with Steve Wolff,
who at the time was the NSF overseer,
National Science Foundation,
overseer of the Internet. And
he said, uh, I said, well,
here's what we're planning on doing.
We're going to build this
website and they will have ads.
But the thing that's different about
the web is that people come to you.
So we're not going to be sending out
anything unless people ask for it.
So it's very different. And
he said, well, you know,
the Internet is about research
and education and if you
guys aren't research and
education, I don't know who is, so go for
it. And it was a wonderful moment. Anyway,
later I organized a meeting where
the term open source software was,
it was widely adopted and promoted it
and particularly told a story about it
that was bigger than the political
movement about free software,
a being against Microsoft by bringing in
the story of why the Internet was also
built on top of open source software.
And that was probably my first experience
of the power of ideas to change
people's minds. You know,
I remember when I first,
I held this press conference at the end
of this day that came to be called the
open source summit.
And I had all these guys up on a stage
and people who nobody had ever heard of,
uh, most of them, you know, and, and
the story I told was so different,
you know,
which had been this story of free software
is this rebel movement that wants to
bring down commercial software. Commercial
software is evil. And I said, hey,
you know, if you guys have uh, you know,
are on the internet and you have a domain
name, yeah. You from the New York Times,
you from the Wall Street Journal or
whatever, you know, this guy over here,
Paul Vicksey wrote the software and gave
it away so that that domain name, uh,
you know, it can be recognized.
Uh, oh, if you send email,
this Guy Eric Almont wrote,
send mail the program that routes at
that point about 70% of all the email on
the Internet, Oh, if you have a
website is probably a patchy. This guy,
Brian Behlendorf started that.
So it kind of,
and it was interesting because I did
about two weeks worth of interviews and in
the beginning what the Internet
is based on free software.
And it was this disbelief and it felt a
little bit like you're trying to push,
you know, something really heavy and it
doesn't move and then it starts to move.
And within two weeks it was just
the accepted wisdom and that, uh,
in in a way is a backdrop to the story
of the book because I'm trying to change
the accepted wisdom again with this book.
So I did it again with web two. Dot.
O uh,
which is really the story for me of
what came back after the s the.com bust.
What was the second coming of the web?
And they come to the conclusion from
thinking about open source in a very
different way than other
people had that uh,
the west, something very different
about the companies that survived.
And of course this led me down the path
that we're really moving out of the
world of,
uh,
that we knew in the PC era where software
was an artifact to where software was
increasingly a business process that is,
were these vast cloud applications that
actually had people inside of them.
And that data was going to be the
source of competitive advantage.
And that was the heart of what I
talked about. Web Two. Dot. Oh,
we also launched something called the
maker Movement with a magazine in 2004
called make and maker faire.
I spent a lot of time in the last
seven or eight years talking about how
government also needs to learn about
platforms from the technology industry.
And most recently I've been talking a
lot in the same way about how to think
differently about AI and what
I called the next economy.
It's a technology and the future
of work. So we also, you know,
a big part of our business today or
conferences we just had last week,
the O'Reilly Ai Conference
this week in New York,
this strata of the business of data. We
doing a conference on Jupiter. We've,
our original very first conference
started in [inaudible] 97,
the O'Reilly open source software
summit. We run makerfair, uh,
something called bootcamp, which Hal
talked about, which is an unconference.
And then we have a platform of our
own, which we started in 2000, uh,
it's called Safari was
originally an ebook platform,
but it's increasingly a platform.
Uh, yes, 40,000 plus Ebooks,
tens of thousands of hours of
video training, live training,
millions of customers. It's really
a platform for knowledge exchange.
And that's really the heart
of our business. We're
about 20% books, 30% events,
and 50% this,
this online learning platform.
So I spent a lot of time thinking about
platforms because that really is the
heart of my business.
And I think that Google also
obviously is a platform company,
but I want to spend a lot of time,
I spend a lot of time in the book thinking
about digital platforms and what they
teach us about economies. I said,
I'm going to come back to that.
So the title of the
Book Wtf, you know, uh,
now I actually use this and the White
House frontiers conference and I was
really proud that I got the White House
comms team to sign off on a talk called
WTF. Uh, but I, and I did
it by kind of saying, well,
it's stands for what's
the future of course.
But really the reason why I wanted to use
the term WTF is because it's a term of
astonishment that can be the astonishment
of delight or the astonishment of
dismay.
And I think that really encapsulates the
state of our dialogue about technology
today is this source of enormous
astonishment and wonder.
And it is also a source of fear.
And I started worrying about this,
uh,
probably two or three years ago,
I started a,
an event called the next economy summit
because I was trying to get ahead of
this issue. How do we think
about technology and the economy?
How do we get technologists to think about
it and to talk about it in a way that
doesn't make people afraid?
How do we get business plans that are
focused on empowering people and building
wealth for everyone rather than simply,
well, we're just going to disrupt,
you know, we're going to
break things. You know,
we're going to make ourselves really,
really rich and we're not gonna really
worry about what happens to everybody
else. And that's how the rest of the
world is starting to see Silicon Valley.
And a lot of ways the book is an attempt
to address that narrative head on and
to change it. Uh, and, and to
change it by actually inspiring,
uh, software developers and entrepreneurs
to act differently, to talk differently,
but also to persuade policy makers
to think and act differently.
So I'm going to try to give you a few
sampling of some of the ideas from the
book anyway,
back to this WTF of amazement or dismay.
This is the world of techno
optimism that we all live in.
That's a chart of life expectancy,
life expectancy at birth,
pretty much flat. I mean,
there's a few really bad times you can
kind of see where it really dropped,
but then suddenly this magical thing
happened in the mid 18 hundreds when it
started to climb. And then
you see additional countries
sort of come on stream.
This is the modern world that we have
every reason to be so proud of, you know,
that we, you know, there's a wonderful
site, our world and data, which is really,
it's this incredible collection of
graphs and narratives about the way that
technology is making the world better.
I'm standing in front of this,
sorry about that guys. Um, so I
guess I'll be back over here. Uh,
so, you know, but everyone
is not equally happy.
We see all Brett's Brexit,
the rise of Trump. And here's,
here's this WTF, you know,
on the Daily Telegraph,
you know, um, and you know,
the question is this is not the first
time when we have had this kind of upset
and worry about technology.
This is a, you know,
an etching about the luddite rebellion.
Now,
one of the things I learned that many
of you may not know is that Ned Lud did
not actually exist. Uh, he, he was
not the leader of the Luddites.
He was a mythical figure that this
particular revolution in 18, 11, 18,
12 cited. He was somebody who
had apparently had smashed
Allume 30 years before.
And it went down his story and they kind
of carried the banner of Ned Lud. Uh,
but here's the point.
These guys were right to be afraid
because the ensuing years were pretty bad.
You know,
and you think about the early years
of the industrial revolution and,
uh, you know, William Blake's description
of the dark satanic mills, uh, you know,
this was not a good time,
but you know,
those weavers could not imagine
the wealth of modern society.
They couldn't imagine that their
descendants would, you know,
this production is mass
production of fabric, you know,
would produce a world in
which their grandchildren
and great grandchildren would
have more clothing than the kings
and Queens of Europe. Did, you know,
the turn of the 18th century or
the 19th century rather, you know,
they couldn't imagine, you know, their
descendants would have, you know,
fruit in the middle of winter.
They couldn't imagine that
we would actually build
skyscrapers half a mile high.
That we dig a tunnel under
the English Channel to France,
that we'd go into space,
that we'd fly through the air.
All these things are amazing and they
couldn't imagine that their descendants
would find so much meaningful work
bringing all these things to life.
And so one of the questions I'm asking
in the face of today's world of AI and
all of these new technologies
that were being told again, again,
are going to destroy jobs.
What does our failure of imagination,
what are we not able to imagine and what
world are we not able to paint for our
grandchildren of the world
to come? And so, you know,
one of the things that I start the book
with is a little excursion into this
idea of fitness landscapes. Now, you know,
in evolutionary biology is this idea
that genes contribute to survival and
organism,
that you can think about this as kind
of a landscape of peaks and valleys and
organisms evolve towards the peaks which
are adapted to their environment or
they die out. And so there's
this concept of a local maximum.
And you know,
a lot of what happens is society and
companies get comfortable with this local
maximum and they don't
know how to move on.
And often the only way to move off of it
is actually to go backwards. You know,
you have to go down. And that's why
we have this cycle sometimes of,
of revolutions of, of, you know, companies
you know, fall apart anyway. But,
uh, you know, fitness landscapes
are, you know, dynamic. You know,
when conditions are stable,
you can kind of just stay there.
But if things are changing, uh, not,
not so, so good. And of course we have,
uh, you know, radically
changing conditions. You know,
climate change is a great example.
If you look at the failure of
many civilizations in the past,
they were driven by climate change.
We may face a great deal of pressure on
our fitness landscape today as a result
of that. Uh, and technology also as
a fitness landscape, you know, uh,
you know, in my career
I watched, you know,
this fitness landscape of the
personal computer, uh, you know,
the big data and AI world,
uh, that, that, you know,
Google lives in the smartphone, a
landscape dominated. That was, yes,
a really broken open by apple and now
it was sort of a subject of fierce
competition between Google and apple.
And you know,
what's really interesting and when
you think about what happened,
why was it hard for Microsoft to
get to the big data world? Well,
they had too much,
you know,
this is a perfect illustration
of the fitness landscape.
They had a business model that really
worked for them and they fought.
Yeah. There were people who were saying,
no, we got to get with the Internet.
And they were kind of like, no,
we have to preserve windows.
And that was their priority. And I think
it's something that we always have to,
to uh, to think about the, this. Dot.
The dominant companies
tend to be slow to adapt.
So, um, you know, the,
the thing is that one of the problems
is that those dominant companies tend to
extract too much of the value from the
ecosystem for themselves. You know,
Microsoft basically put other
companies out of business.
They would come down to silicon valley,
meet with vcs and say,
you can't invest there because
we're going to do that. Uh, and,
and this is a real risk, I
think for Google as well. You
know, it, it, it's really,
I think a mistake to think,
uh,
just value for users,
you know,
because Google will make a case what
we're doing this thing and it's better for
our customers. But you actually have
to think about the whole ecosystem.
And in particular, you have to think about
the ecosystem of developers. You know,
the people you know,
went to Lennox and the worldwide web
because there was no room left in the
Microsoft ecosystem.
So they went somewhere,
they didn't think they were going to
go make a lot of money over on the web.
They just went, this is cool, this is
interesting. And it's free and open. And,
and that sort of free and open was what
gave birth to the new fitness landscape.
You know, the, the,
the small mammals coming out from the
valleys into this new fitness peak.
So again, it's always something to worry
about if you're as dominant as Google,
uh, is, is to think about, you know,
are we making enough value for these
developers who are part of our ecosystem,
these people who are creating on top
of our platform and making it a rich,
stable ecosystem? Or are we basically
saying, no, no, we're, you know,
we, we have to do that
for ourselves. You know,
I had that experience many times with
Microsoft, you know, it's like, oh,
that's a great idea. We
have to do that. Sorry. Uh,
so in our, in our political landscape,
we're seeing this same thing.
You know, we've had this
idea that by making a small
number of people very, very,
very wealthy,
uh,
it would trickle down to the rest of the
society has an entirely work that way.
And guess what, you know, the people are
moving somewhere else. They're saying,
we don't like that consensus
about how to run the world. Uh,
we're going to do it differently. They may
even be wrong. And maybe, you know, well,
not in my opinion, I even a
May, but, uh, you know, uh,
uh,
there's a real serious risk that the
conditions that we have know that we
silicon valley have used to thrive,
are going to change radically because
of the political environment. And so,
you know, one of the key pieces
of advice I give him my book is,
is just to remember the
successful ecosystem creates
opportunity for everyone.
And, and this obviously was
brought into the, you know,
the political discourse by Thomas
Piketty's book capital in the 21st century
where he really addressed this question
of inequality and got everybody talking
about it. There had been
other people, you know,
Joe Stieglitz had written about the 99%
versus the 1% before picket aid come out.
But, and that, that almost
caught, but you know, you know,
when [inaudible] book came out, it was
like everybody started talking about it.
And so I decided to take a technological
angle on all of this to kind of tell
the story from the point of
view of the tech industry.
Because a lot of people talking about it
as economists and I was so in a lot of
ways,
the heart of the book is,
is a series of stories about what the
great technology platforms have to tell us
about the future of
business and the economy.
And the first is this
point I've already made.
The platforms have to work
for all of their participants,
not just for the users or the platform
owner is also the point that platforms
today are no longer just about the
digital right there in mashed in the real
world. You know, you think
about Uber or Lyft, you know,
this is really this system. You think
about this huge algorithmic system.
And sure, there are people at the end
points of all the touch points of Google.
You know,
people are uploading youtube videos or
they're clicking on links are there,
they're submit, you know,
creating webpages. But boy,
it becomes really obvious
that human beings are a,
as this, uh, Sean McMullan,
the science fiction authors are our
souls in the great machine. You know,
when you have these cars dispatched
by algorithm with drivers,
you have the swarming marketplace
where people are doing things in the,
in the real world. You're at the
Beck and call of algorithms. So, uh,
so, you know, we have to start
thinking about, you know,
this interpenetration of the digital
into all of our business processes,
into all of our world.
Uh, you know, as, uh,
as we effectively take the principles
that we've been practicing in the purely
digital realm for,
uh,
the last couple of decades and start to
see them show up everywhere in the real
world.
So it becomes even more important.
And the third key point is
that the fundamental function
of every technology is
that it augments people so they can do
things that were previously impossible.
You know, we couldn't fly
through the air and now we can.
And so when you think about, you
know, what AI is going to do,
there's a strong narrative that it's
going to put people out of work.
And instead,
I think the narrative,
we need to be seeking out the narrative
of what will it let us do that we can't
do today,
that will be wonderful,
that will make us full
of that WTF of delight.
And we have to tell that story
powerfully and we have to believe it.
And we have to build products and
startups that deliver on that promise.
So, um, you know,
and there is kind of this interesting
thing that of course the WTF of delight
becomes banal. I still remember once, uh,
landing in Sydney airport in Australia
and they had this giant mural,
and I wish I could find the name of the
photographer because it's long gone now.
But it was thousands of people turned
out to see the first airplane come to
Australia, you know, and it was just
this, these faces looking up in wonder.
He has been a voyage of, you know, many
months, you know, for many of, you know,
people that emigrate and then it's like
they're connected to the world and it's
like, oh my God. And now you think about,
you know, Airlines, oh my God, you know,
you know,
so the WTF of wonder actually later
became the WTF of dismay and we have to
watch out for that. But the, um, uh,
you know, that, that source
of wonder is so important,
but this idea of augmentation,
let me kind of come back to Uber and Lyft.
You know,
when you think about that experience,
there's a couple of things.
The first is this magical
experience, which goes away
because you get used to it.
Wow, I can, you know, I don't have to
call a taxi company and hope they show up.
I don't have to stand out on the street
corner and wave another all full.
Or there's nobody there.
I can summon a car,
I get an estimate of when it's going
to be there and I walk out and it just
comes magic,
you know,
realizing the capability that
was hidden in our phones, uh, to,
to match people in a real time
matching marketplace. Right? But also,
and this is one of the things a lot of
people don't understand about Uber and
Lyft, you know, it's like taxi companies
go, well we have to have an APP,
but we hate this idea of part
time drivers who just, you know,
show up and don't have licenses.
And you go, well guess what?
All the parts of that business
model work together. Uh,
because it's because you have those part
time drivers that you can have three
minute pickup times, uh, all of the
time. You don't run out of cabs, right?
Cause they're harnessing the
marketplace in this new algorithmic way.
And the reason they can do that is because
the drivers are augmented with this
new cognitive augmentation called
Google maps or ways or you know,
it's built now into,
into the APP. You know,
it's like people don't have to have the
knowledge of the streets and monuments
of London. They can just turn on the
APP and it says, turn right here.
Right. And you know, the, the,
literally the knowledge is a
test where you are a human gps.
You're like a men tat out
of Frank Herbert's Dune. You
know, where you literally,
they give you two points in London and
you have to recite the turn by turn to
get from one to the other. And you know,
now you don't have to do that. So that,
that cognitive augmentation also is
going to make new things possible.
Just like the steam shovel or the,
you know,
steel girder or the steel
beam in the physical world.
Cognitive augmentation allows people
to do new things that they couldn't do
before. So, um,
I also talk a lot about the fact that
these systems are algorithmic systems,
at least today infused with AI,
but these algorithmic systems have a sort
of a fitness function or an objective
function.
And I want to talk about that in the
context of the economy in a bit because I
think the real, uh, Israel's
significance for society,
the economy and the future of the human
race in the algorithms that we are
building into our future. Then we're
going to talk about that in a minute.
So there's a bunch of my writing on
the topic of it's not in the book.
You can find out the site WTF,
economy.com as well as some content
that's in the book anyway and come back to
this notion of platform must create more
value than it captures. And that's been,
uh, kind of the heart of what we try
to do it or Riley, um, uh, you know,
we invited in our biggest competitors
into our platform when we launched it.
We continue to think about how do we make
money for them as well as for us. Uh,
and I think Google should,
I,
I've loved what Hal has done with the
Google economic impact reports because
it's starting to tell a story which should
be told by every business in America,
every business in the world,
which is how are we creating value
for other people, for others,
not just for ourselves, all
of his financial reporting.
That's just about, wow,
look how well we're doing.
Great. I go, well, how, you know,
there are companies that are doing well
by making other people do badly and we
have to actually have a
system wide accounting of
what people are putting in and
what they're taking out.
In the alternative,
if you are a Google like company where
you are a systematic platform companies,
you'd become a regulated utility because
if people say, wow, you are not uh,
you know, looking after your ecosystem,
well we'll look after it for you.
So I think that's something you guys
should be very worried about weight.
I want to kind of come back,
I've talked about a lot of this already,
but this is something that out
of the book, this notion of a,
I call a business model map business
model is the way that all the parts of a
business work together to
create customer value. And uh,
I first was introduced to this concept
by some consultants called Dan Meredith
being back in 2000.
And they actually used the example of
southwest airlines versus hub and spoke
airlines. And they kind of went
through how all the parts of,
of southwest,
uh,
business actually make them very
different than the other airlines,
even though they're all in the
airline business, you know,
so they don't forward baggage.
They don't have assigned seats.
This actually is different.
And so Google and Facebook,
both in the advertising business,
but you have very different parts of
your business model. So for example, uh,
with, with Google, right? Somebody,
your customer succeeds when they come to
Google, get what they want and go away,
right? So your success is aligned with
people leaving Google coming and leaving
Facebook. Success is aligned
with having people come and stay.
And that's a huge difference in your
business model and a huge lever if you are
competing with Facebook for example,
because you have to say, Oh wow,
we have to find more reasons
to get people to go away
and not to get people to come and stay
with us because then you're, you're,
you're playing on Facebook's
uh, uh, you know, turf.
And as Sun Tzu says, attack your enemy
where he is strong and you are weak.
I mean, we're here as weekend. You
are strong. So anyway, back to this,
I tried to draw a model of Uber because
it seemed to me to be a kind of a,
uh, a kind of a template for what starting
to happen in the economy. You know,
you have these companies
that are platforms,
they're not just sort of
traditional companies, you know,
they're replacing ownership with
access, you know, and they've got this,
this marketplace managed by an algorithm,
you know,
with passengers matching
up passengers and drivers.
And there's a bunch of things,
know workers supplying their own cars,
independent contractors, you know,
that are really part of this, uh,
you know, this story. And, uh, you know,
this augmented workers idea that we
talked about magical x user experience.
So all of these things go together.
And one of the things we
have to understand this,
we think about technology and the
economy is what things go together in our
business model.
What things belong and what things
to fight against it. And so,
for example, at a Riley, one of
the things that we've, you know,
realized that made us able to transition
from being a publishing company to be a
conference company in an online learning
company, was that we realized we were,
we were really a company that was about
connecting people who knew something
with people who wanted
to learn it from them.
And so we were able to evolve how we did
that because we really understood that.
Whereas a lot of our
competitors, uh, you know,
most of them no longer really
in the business very much.
They just thought their job was to
capture knowledge into books and put it on
shelves. So anyway, so, uh, I, you know,
I spent some time really trying to think
through business models and how they
work and how the changing in
the age of the platform. Uh,
I've talked a little bit about this
thick marketplace idea. A house, uh, uh,
student Jonathan Hall,
who's the chief economist at Uber
turned me onto this book. Alvin Roth.
So who gets what and why, uh, which
is really about, uh, you know,
how do you make a successful
matching marketplace,
which is at the heart of so many
of the great platforms today.
And so that kind of led me to
this, you know, this path of, of,
of thinking about marketplaces.
But then again,
I talked about this augmented
in a worker concept,
but this is a really key part of it.
Uh,
and that is really something I call
the arc of knowledge. You know,
when we think about how do we communicate
knowledge, we first, you know, we, we,
we spoke it to each other and
then we wrote it down, you know,
things like maps and,
and you thinking about the
first iterations of online
maps and they were kind of
reproductions of printed maps just online,
which was kind of Nice.
And then you got maps and directions
and you go all the way up to automated
vehicles and you see that the knowledge
disappears into a service. And that's,
it seems to me to be a key point to
remember when you think about how are we
augmenting workers,
we're basically building these cognitive
augmentations that will just disappear
in the services where you
don't necessarily need to
know in advance things,
you know, this is already
so true. You know, we were
talking over lunch about how,
oh yeah, yeah. Some technique.
How do you learn it?
You go to youtube and you watch the
video and before long maybe we will be in
the place like trinity in
the Matrix where we can say,
I need to know how to fly a helicopter.
And I remember she downloads
the knowledge, you know,
but even without that,
we're going to have these augmented
devices that capture and share human
knowledge. So when I
think about, you know, AI,
that's my starting point is that
it's a tool for human augmentation.
It isn't this radical in a discontinuity.
You know,
this machine from the future that's going
to make humans obsolete any more than,
you know, uh, machines in our,
of the industrial era were somehow going
to make humans obsolete, you know? Sure.
Yeah. We're not as strong probably
as most of our, uh, you know, uh,
even if we work out a lot,
we're probably not as strong or as fit as,
as someone who worked every day on the
farm or doing, you know, prayer work.
I still remember going to Hawaii once
and huffing and puffing up over some hill
and it was like,
oh yeah,
the ancient Hawaiians took him about
20 minutes to open over to the other,
you know, waterfall and we
took us two hours, you know,
um, yeah, you know, we're not,
you know, as fit, but we are more
capable if you've ever read guns,
germs and steel,
you know,
it opens through this wonderful
passage yet Yalies question, you know,
guy in, in, in New Guinea saying,
you know, you guys are so stupid.
You know, if I took you in the jungle
he'd be dead in two weeks. I'll come.
You have all the cargo.
Yeah. And you know,
and that is in fact the question
of our civilization. You know,
it's like we are making, you
know, a ourselves smarter,
stronger, faster, better.
And that should be how we frame and how
we think about what we're doing with
technology. It's not disruptive. It's
not destroyed. It's not eliminate,
it's empower, it's lift up,
its make things possible. So,
you know, technology is
our superpower. You know,
and this is another one of
the charts from, um, you know,
our world and data of, uh, you know,
the number of people in the world living
in absolute poverty and you wash that
incredibly steep decline
and that's wonderful. But
inequality is our Kryptonite.
And we have, you know, this
is a, you know, from the,
we are the 99% story we have to confront
that. We have to think about it as a,
particularly as a, as a society,
but also as an industry.
So one of my interesting
questions, uh, is, uh,
that I tried to explore in the book is
what keeps us from creating prosperity
for everyone.
And here's the answer.
And this is the connected taxicab circuit.
2005.
Uh, you know, it's like, wow, we had
connected taxicabs. What'd we do?
We put a screen in the back where people
could look up information where they
can watch ads, you know, and
we totally missed, you know,
even though actually Sunil Paul in 2000
had written a series of patents about
what would be possible, uh, if you, you
know, you tried to connect, you know,
cars with smartphones and it actually,
they weren't really even smartphones,
but with gps and phones, it
was just too early, right?
So there was this sort
of cognitive filter, this
cognitive blindness, you know,
you kill actually sort
of framing blindness,
maybe the right way to sit where we framed
the world in a particular way and we
couldn't see what was possible.
And I think this is a critical problem.
And I've watched it throughout
my career. You know, when I,
in 2000 I had to lead this
a protest against, uh, uh,
Jeff Bezos is one click patent. And
we went and we looked, uh, you know,
Jeff kind of worked with
me to try to, uh, you know,
turn it around from a PR point of view.
I, one of the things we did was we,
we started a us,
we funded a startup called bounty quest,
which looked for prior art on,
you know,
one click shopping and we couldn't find
it because basically it was sort of
unthinkable of the time people were afraid
to put their credit cards online and
they had the Shah, the
shopping cart metaphor, they
kind of understood the world.
It was very much like this
connecting taxi cab circa 2005.
So I, the reason I tell you that story
actually, and then here's another one.
You know, it's like I asked Tony
Fidel, why didn't, you know, uh,
you guys do the connected speaker and he
says, well, can you imagine, you know, if,
if, uh, people had had thought
Google is listening to me, you know,
somebody had to make that possible first.
You know, because there was just this,
you know, because of Google's
particular position in the market,
you couldn't be the first mover,
but you still have to understand that
these cognitive shifts do happen where
people believe that something else
is possible. But more than that,
I want to actually take that thinking
to the political and the economic realm.
And this is where I start to get out of my
depth in the book and, but uh, but I, I,
this is maybe it's just
a thought experiment,
but maybe just maybe it's something
that's really worth thinking about.
And this is the beginning of,
of actually an argument that runs through
a central section of the book and it's
about sort of AI and algorithmic systems
and their relationship to human society.
And I asked the question,
you know,
what is strong AI bears the same
relationship to today's narrow AI as
multicellular life does to a
single celled forebears. Now,
right now we keep thinking that we're
going to create a strong AI. Maybe,
you know,
maybe it will be 1520 years from now,
maybe 50 maybe it will be a hundred
but it will be like us, you know,
a single self aware being. And, you know,
I wonder if instead, you
know, it's a collective being,
and it turns out that that is what
happened in this prokaryotic to eukaryotic
cell transition because it turns out
that this is thing that Lynn Margulis in
1967 actually it was, I think it was
originally in, in, uh, uh, again, uh,
constant and marriage choskey in
2019 oh five at first proposed it,
but she picked it up at 67 and it
actually proved it over, uh, you know,
a lot of years of being
ridiculed and pushed back.
And it was this idea that,
uh,
that multicell organisms actually
incorporated bacteria into them. You know,
so it turns out it was latest
substantiated by genetic evidence that
Mitochondria in our body are actually
bacteria that came and lived inside of us.
Right? Uh, same thing with
chloroplasts in plants. They're there.
They have totally different genetic
material than the nucleus of the cell.
And so in a similar way,
I started thinking, well,
what if we are somehow like
that with our computers?
And of course, biological
symbiosis doesn't start with that.
Symbio Genesis that Lynn Margo was
talked about this also this increasing
knowledge of the microbiome,
how we are really a colony organism.
Ed Young in his wonderful book I
contain multitudes, has all zoology,
is really ecology. You know, when
we look at beetles and elephants,
sea urchins and earthworms parents and
friends, we see individuals, you know,
uh, driven by a single brain and
operating with a single genome.
And this is a pleasant fiction.
You know, we're legion, you know,
he says he'd Walt Whitman, I
am large. I contain multitudes.
So think about this in humans too.
You know, when we talk about, uh,
you know, unsupervised learning as the
holy grail of Ai, I go, yeah, you know,
humans have some amount
of unsupervised learning.
We have a shit ton of supervised learning.
You know,
we learn our language from our
parents. Uh, everything we, you know,
we know that makes us able to,
you know,
to do the kinds of things that we do here
at Google. We were taught by somebody.
And then on top of that, yes, we're
able to do unsupervised learning,
but we have a long way to
go. Uh, you know, I think in,
in the supervised learning of this new
organism before we can kind of even
expect to see it start to
do on supervised. Not like
you start necessarily there,
but, um, you know, so, so
thinking about this as a metaphor,
I started thinking about, I've been
really thinking about this for the last,
you know, 10, 15 years, you know,
how increasingly we're, all,
all of humanity is being woven into this
new global mind, the Super Ai, you know,
and we're seeing in things like fake news,
kind of the equivalent of our neuroses,
you know, the equivalent of, of, uh, of,
of bad ideas, you know, the spread
incredibly quickly now and are adopted by,
you know,
millions of people and then encoded
further into the systems that we build.
You know,
so we're this really interesting phase
of symbiosis and we have to come and
understand it. And, uh, so,
and we think that our emergent
Prodo AI's are also compound being.
It's just like, we are, what
would we do differently?
How would we think about them and
what do we know about them today? And,
uh,
you know,
there's a lot of fear of some kind
of future hostile AI. And I go, well,
if there is one,
we are already training it.
We already teaching it and what
are we teaching it? So, you know,
when you think about this further,
you know, we, we're seeing, you know,
this compound being, you know, this,
we see the rise of specialized chips,
which actually, uh, you know,
is actually a pretty interesting
imitation of neuroscience.
But here it is a great one. You're
here. Here's one of the, uh, you know,
the Mitochondria inside the
Google brain, right? Uh,
and, uh, you know, it,
here's this thing we've even defined
in our legal system starting in 1888 we
said that there's this thing
called a corporate person.
It's really just this collective organism
that was the case called consolidated
silver mining versus Pennsylvania.
It's like under the designation of person.
There's no doubt that a
private corporation is included
in the 14th amendment,
such corporations,
Emilia associations of individuals who
United for special purpose, right? So,
you know, special purpose
organism, you know, and guess what,
we now have these special purposes of
organisms are increasingly digital,
increasingly quick,
increasingly algorithmic.
We're making these special
purpose organisms. Uh, uh, and,
and what are we asking them to do?
And I believe that one of the things that
we have to come to grips with is that
in some ways these ais,
that our children are
already ruling human society.
And we have to ask ourselves, what is
the motivation of this new species?
And this is obviously, you know, kind of
out there, but think about it, you know,
how does Google decide
what it's going to do?
Well, we actually, we collectively, you
know, starting with Larry and Sergei and,
uh, you know, all the early founders,
but people like Hal and all of you
have actually put thoughts into this,
you know, shared Google
brain, you've trained that,
you've taught it and you've taught it
that it should optimize for relevance.
And this is this sort
of master organizing,
objective function of
everything that Google does,
whether it's in search or advertising,
it's like find the thing
that people are looking for.
So you've kind of built this
special purpose organism that has,
you know, these, these goals
built into it, baked into it.
And those goals actually now exist
independently of any of the people who
created it. Like again, they, they, they
will, you know, it will die just like, uh,
you know, uh, you know, a
biological organism will die
under certain conditions,
but it doesn't actually depend on
any individual cells to remain.
You know,
we've all been told that our bodies
can completely recycle the completely
different cells. Uh, yeah,
every seven years I think it
is. And, you know, same thing,
all the people can cycle out and this
organism would continue with the same
programming, with this continually
adapting program. So think about that.
So Google relevance,
Facebook engagement,
and we saw with Facebook and fake
news how that can go wrong, you know,
and it basically reminds me,
I guess,
a of the story of Mickey
Mouse in the broomsticks. And
fantasia, you know, I mean,
all of these systems,
we tell them what to do when we set them
going and they do what we told them to
do, but we don't necessarily
quite understand it.
And this is the story that comes out
again and again in Arabian mythology,
you know, with genies and uh,
you know, you, you told them, uh,
this is actually an illustration by
Edmund Dulac from the thousand and one
nights. Uh, but it's sort
of a rising of great power,
but what's it going to do is going
to do what we told it. But we made,
we didn't understand and we
didn't tell it quite right.
Mark thought that by building this
social platform that was focused on
engagement and you know,
he would build real community and then
he found instead that we've created this
monster, which he is now trying to
bring back under control. You know,
that's actually part of
the experience. So, uh,
many years ago,
a friend of mine said to me,
this is in the early days of
mackintosh programming. He said,
the art of debugging is figuring out
what you really told you programmed to do
rather than what you
thought you told it to do.
And we are right now engaged
in that process with these,
these new digital gin that we
have created. We are saying,
are they doing what we meant?
Are we doing? Are they doing,
you know what we told them to do?
But it wasn't quite what we had asked.
And how do we fix that?
That's what you do every day at Google.
You try to actually go, yes, is it
doing what we really meant it to do?
And now my question is, are we doing
that same thing in our broader society?
You know,
because here's the data that we see that
is at the heart of this economic unease
that we're facing,
which is that this wonderful gift,
the WTF of amazement is that
productivity has continued to go up.
You know,
if you look,
this is from 1945 up
through 2015 is pretty,
my God, it's a graph that ray
Kurzweil would be proud of.
It's just up until the right,
right?
And then you see this divergence
starting around 1970s,
a real family income. Somehow that
productivity was not getting through,
not being distributed to ordinary people.
Now it's a lot of reasons why that
may have gone wrong is you know,
people like Hal study this, uh,
and, and, and his, his, his, uh,
his ill cause is what economists do.
Uh,
and I'm not saying what I'm
proposing is the only cause,
but I think it is one of them.
And that is this,
here's another one of these
ais, these pro ais, you know,
that we tell it what to do and is it
really doing what we think and this is the
Equinix and why for data center,
which is sort of one of the hearts of the,
of our financial trading system.
And this is kind of the skynet of the
story because ultimately we told these are
financial system what its
objective function should be.
Milton Friedman in 1970 wrote an article
in the New York Times called the social
responsibility of business
is to increase its profits.
The businesses should not think
about anything other than that.
And if they did that,
they would pass along the profits to the
shareholders and the shareholders could
make up their own mind.
This is a perfectly reasonable thesis,
just like some of the theses
that you put into your code.
But when you build code and you watch it,
you do,
you actually do that debugging process.
You say,
did it do what I asked it to do?
And we have to ask ourselves when we said,
you know,
optimize for share price,
in particular optimized for
profits and the profits.
This proxy is the share price
of companies optimize for that,
not for people, you know? Yeah.
If it makes sense, you know,
outsourced to factories. If it makes
sense. Got that community, you know,
because you know, your, your master
fitness function, the thing that we,
the wish that we expressed to the genie
we built was make my share price go up.
And uh, you know, this is actually,
there are a lot of people in the financial
industry who are starting to take
note of this. I mean, you know,
uh, Larry Fink, who runs blackrock,
the largest asset manager in the world,
has been railing about stock buy backs,
uh, Warren Buffet questioning. And
then there's a number of books.
This one makers and takers is really
good other than the golden passport about
how Harvard business school
kind of wreck the economy. But,
so this idea that the financial markets,
which are really meant to support the
human economy and become this extractive
platform that basically says, no,
no, no, gives the money to us.
You know? And, and we have
to actually reverse that.
And that's what I want to come
back to this story about the,
a little screen in the back of the
taxi cab and the failure of imagination
because it's very hard for us to
imagine a completely different world,
you know, so when we talk about
tax reform will, it's like,
we'll push this rate up in that rate
down. You know, that's not how it happens.
The great revolutions are ones where
you really imagined the world in new.
And we're good at that in technology
and we think about that all the time.
And we need to do it also in the
world of politics and the economy.
And we have done that before.
You know,
when the founders of this country,
you know,
got together and said,
we're going to try to build a new
country with a new set of ideas,
you know, oh my God. You know,
there's that famous story
about King George when George
Washington stepped down,
you know,
uh,
basically originally and he won the war.
You know,
all the Europeans expected that George
Washington would become the king of
America. And, and George the
third is reported reporter said,
yeah. And he went back to his farm and
said, and then George King George said,
if he has done that, now he has the
greatest man in the world has ever seen.
It was this unthinkable thing,
you know,
so much more on thinkable than
Uber was to a taxi company.
Or that one click was through,
uh, an ecommerce site. And
it was amazing, you know,
and we can do that,
you know?
So if we are entering a world where AI
can do so much more of the jobs that we
do today, you know, we should
not be content to say, well,
we'll just kind of keep feeding
the current system. You know,
I have Cory Doctorow, the science
fiction writer had this great, uh, uh,
statement on social media
recently where he said,
a economists use equations to
justify the divine right of capital.
The way that corridor astrologers used,
uh,
the stars to justify the divine
right of kings. And yeah,
whether it's true or not, it's true in
the spiritual world. This idea that,
you know,
we,
we basically justify the system as it is
rather than imagining the system as it
could be.
And I see this enormous opportunity to
make a more prosperous world with all of
these technologies we have,
you know, so, you know, uh,
the what makes me hopeful is first of all,
that when we build these
algorithmic systems,
we can start to see ourselves better
bias and coded and taken to scale becomes
visible. You know, when,
you know, when we have been,
uh,
arresting blacks at a much
higher rate and not seeing it,
it's just kind of in the woodwork. You
know, we'd go wells, human bias, you know.
Sure. But then all of a
sudden when you're going, wow,
we're baking it into the end of the
algorithms because we're using these
training datasets that are based
on decades of bias policing.
We can suddenly see it, we can
fix it. We can debug our society.
You know? So that's the first thing, you
know, it's like this whole engagement,
this digitalization of our world is
going to help us understand our world and
make it better. And the
second thing, you know,
AI is going to help us to understand more
deeply what is human and it can create
new kinds of beauty. And I love this, uh,
this a statement from the 37th move
of the second game. Uh, it was a fan.
Who are you talking about?
He says it's not a human move.
I've never seen a human play
this move so beautiful. You know,
this idea that something new that we
have not imagined can be beautiful,
that it can not be something
you'd be afraid of.
That it can be something wonderful
that's the world that I think we and the
technology industry should be
committed to creating. And finally,
just want to remember that
it isn't technology that
wants to eliminate jobs. Uh,
my friend Nick Hanauer or said technology
is the solution to human problems.
We won't run out of work until
we run out of problems. So like,
I think we all in our industry have
to commit ourselves to solving human
problems, make it work, make
the world a better place.
So that's the master design pattern of
technology and really the message of the
book,
you know,
our job is to augment people so they
can do things that were previously
impossible.
Thanks.
Well Tim, thanks so much for coming. I'm
really excited to read your book. Uh,
I was just curious,
you know,
as someone who's been in the publishing
and content industry for the past 20
years,
why,
when you think about it sort of like
transmitting these ideas about the future,
why you chose to do it in the
form of a book, when there's like,
there's lots of different
tools out there today and like,
so as someone who's thought a lot about
this, I'm just kind of curious, like what,
like why do you choose to,
cannot close it?
That's really good point actually.
In a,
probably the trigger was that I had,
I've been running this event called the
next economy summit and I was trying to
get on Michael Crafts, uh, you know,
show the local PBS show and I
just was having a lot of trouble.
And then somebody who'd written a book
that I really didn't respect, sort of,
you know, appears on the show. And
I'm like, Damn, you know, it's like,
it's free for a certain kind of
intellectual discussion. It is still,
uh, you know, the, the
little entry card, you know,
like I couldn't get in this room without
the Google entry card. And you know,
writing the book gets you discussed
by the policymakers because that's the
thing,
you know,
all of these people who
shouldn't be deeply involved
in the digital because it's
the center of our world, you know, I
mean this is a book that I can send,
I can put in front of a
policymaker, have them read, uh,
have the think tanks in DC.
Talk about,
I can give talks there because
I wrote a book, you know,
and otherwise I'm some
weird new media guy.
And of course you've been a publisher
for 30 years. Yeah. Which is ironic. And,
and actually I didn't publish it myself.
I actually went to one of the traditional
business publishing, uh, you know,
companies because again,
it's sort of, it's, it's just
this credentialing function,
excellent set of hypotheses. But one of
them is the, who are the actors of change.
Obviously we talk like break big things.
Like Uber today has started
as very small things.
Do you have any conclusions
you draw with this?
Whether innovation is possible as they
can to get more and multicellular at the
small stage garage date
and rural startup stage?
Or would you be thinking that as data
gravity of its own that we're going to see
a return to bigness for its own sake
and that potential for startups in this
world?
Well,
I do think first of all,
the power of ideas is
profound. Uh, you know, uh,
even, you know, if a
startup doesn't survive,
it can actually place a new idea into
the world and that idea can be taken up.
And um, you know, that's,
that is, you know,
why create more value than you capture
is sort of part of my motto. You know,
I just believe, yes, you know, in
the end we're all going to fail.
You know, and I, I've often quoted
this wonderful poem of Roca.
What we fight with is so small and
when we win, it makes us small.
What we want is to be defeated decisively
by successively greater beings.
He's talking about wrestling with
the angels. And I think that,
so yes,
that may be a risk of bigness,
but I think actually if you follow the
job of doing something that needs doing,
you know,
like one of my,
one of the companies they talked about
at the end of the book where I kind of
try and give some, hopefully
it's companies zip line, right?
So here's a company that's using drones
and on demand and they're not like,
we're going to be the Uber of dry cleaning
there. They're like, uh, you know,
we're going to be the Uber of blood
delivery in co in a country where,
uh, people, you know,
with the leading cause of death in women
is postpartum hemorrhage. You know,
it was no developed hospital
infrastructure. There's, uh, you know,
bad roads,
but you can get a drone anywhere in
the country and 20 minutes, you know,
and Bang, you know, it's like, that's
astonishing. You know, that's like, wow,
we can solve a problem that's a real
problem with this magical technology.
And guess what? They're kind of
not, they're in there, you know,
in that normal competitive landscape.
Because they've actually found
this green field of opportunity,
which is solving a real problem.
And I think, uh, you know,
if, when, you know, sure, the
[inaudible] space pretty crowded.
And if you want to go, yeah, can I make
another social network kind of hard,
you know, problem. But there's another
piece to it too, which I've been,
I had a debate with Reid Hoffman recently
cause he's got a book coming out on
blitz scaling. And I was like,
look, read it. If, you know,
it's like you got to raise lots of money
because you have to grow faster than
your competitors and so on and so forth.
It's still a winner.
Takes all somebody going to win
and somebody's going to lose.
And one of the things I want
to hear more is, uh, um,
like how are these platforms
enabling an ecosystem? You know,
it's kind of goes back to this sort
of platform thinking, you know,
and you look at,
uh,
you know how Google has been an enabler,
how youtube is an enabler.
You know, there's people getting
work from this. And I think, uh,
one of the things that I think in a
world of winner takes all platforms,
the platforms themselves have to think
more about how are we going to enable a
network of small business
[inaudible].